j'évite de juger ces j'ai eu beaucoup de
chance parce que la plupart de ses films
ont été faits dans une grande liberté
quelquefois je n'ai pas été tout à fait
digne de cette liberté ou de cette
confiance parce que le résultat n'était
pas bon
quelquefois
le film sont venus meilleur que les
scénarios
quelquefois le scénario était très bien
et fils m'a pas rendu aussi bien c'est
un mélange c'est une
c'est pas une carrière complète c'est
une partie probablement la plus grande
partie ils ont vingt carrière parce que
je crois pas que j'aurais encore la
possibilité de faire un film peut-être
encore dix et puis je crois qu'il ya une
alternance de fruits de choses qui sont
à peu près à peu près réussi parce que
c'est un métier tellement dur que je
crois que c'est rarement parfait et ce
n'est pas non plus déshonorant ça va il
ya je crois un honnête pourcentage de
deux réussites et d'échecs là dedans je
crois n'avoir jamais fait des films
pessimistes par exemple même quand je
traite un sujet dur il y a toujours de
l'espoir dedans il ya toujours l'amour
de la vie je suis anti suicidaire par
exemple je n'aimerais pas montré un film
qui encouragerait les gens à se détruire
je crois que la vie est difficile mais
qu'elle est passionnante et je crois que
les films le disent aussi aussi bien
films anciens comme jules et jim k films
plus récents comme la nuit américaine
ces films disent que la vie est
intéressante je crois c'est un passage
qui se fait en plusieurs fois voyez à
travers le fonds s'engage d'abord où je
voulais m'occuper moyen de l'enfant la
nuit américaine où je jouais presque mon
propre rôle de metteur en scène c'est un
autre côté à cause de la ligue
américaine que steven spielberg m'a
proposé de jouer le savant français dans
tout le proche rencontre du troisième
type
et puis voilà et puis j'ai joué le la
chambre verte parce que c'était un film
aussi que je sentais très proche de moi
un peu quand même
françois mais je me vois pas comme un
acteur je me vois comme un metteur en
scène qui de temps en temps envie de
faire tout de faire plus je ne tiens pas
compte du public dans le choix des
sujets vous voyez ce en quoi je n'aurais
pas fait des films comme l'enfant
sauvage la chambre verte qui sont sur
des sujets difficiles mais après dans la
façon de traiter le sujet j'essaie
d'être constamment intéressant d'être
clair de ne pas créer de confusion
et oui j'essaie de plus que le film à
l'arrivée constitue de toute façon un
spectacle n'être que la personne qui a
eu le courage de venir voir le sujet
éventuellement même si le sujet
difficile sorte content on n'y arrive
pas toujours mais on essaye voyez la
production française elle est très
ambitieuse et elle se déroule dans des
conditions matérielles extrêmement
difficile et on connaît toutes les
raisons et elle est beaucoup plus
ambitieuse qu'autrefois quelques fois il
n'a pas tout à fait les moyens son
ambition ou quelquefois il ya un trop
grand décalage entre les ambitions qui
sont très hautes et l'exécution qui peut
être faible manquait de moyens mais le
cinéma français vous savez au nom qui
plutôt du mal en france et on en est
plutôt du bien quand on sort de france
on dit plutôt du bien quand on est en
angleterre en amérique en allemagne
je crois que les
elle et les nobles et elle est bonne à
la critique est moins importante qu
autrefois parce que le cinéma lui-même
c'est tellement diversifiée que le
public est plus réticent pour suivre un
critique pour lui faire confiance parce
que à travers le compte rendu du
critique le public n'arrive pas à savoir
si vraiment il s'agit d'un film qui
pourra lui plaire ou non donc la
critique a perdu de son importance et de
sa puissance et je pense qu'elle devrait
c'est très difficile pour elle de se
ressaisir mais qu'elle devrait quand
même faire une sorte d'examen de
conscience parce que s'il y a des choses
qui ne vont pas dans le cinéma français
il ya aussi des choses qui ne vont pas
dans la critique